This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Recognize the possibilities of nuclear war in the middle age, without our citizens knowing what they should do and where they should go. If bombs begin to fall, it would be a failure of responsibility. And that, of course, is President John F. Kennedy speaking on July 25, 1961, during the Berlin crisis. One of the various moments in the Cold War where we came very, very close to engaging in actual war with the Soviets.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。在中年时期认识到核战争的可能性，而我们的公民却不知道他们该做什么、该去哪里。如果炸弹开始落下，这将是责任的失职。当然，这是约翰·F·肯尼迪总统在 1961 年 7 月 25 日柏林危机期间发表的讲话。这是冷战中我们非常、非常接近与苏联爆发实际战争的几个时刻之一。
Tomorrow, I am requesting of the Congress new funds for the following immediate objectives. To identify and mark space in existing structures, public and private, they could be used for fallout shelters in case of attack. To stock those shelters with food, water, first aid kits, and other minimum essentials for our survival. Basically what Kennedy is saying here is, it's a real possibility that bombs are going to start falling and we need to figure out where you can all go to take shelter if they do.
明天，我将向国会申请新的资金，用于实现以下直接目标。确定并标记现有建筑（无论是公共还是私人的）中的空间，以便在发生袭击时用作防空洞。为这些防空洞储备食物、水、急救包以及我们生存的其他基本必需品。肯尼迪在这里表达的意思基本上是，炸弹开始落下的可能性是真实存在的，如果真的发生这种情况，我们需要弄清楚大家可以去哪里避难。
That's producer Katie Mingle. And after Kennedy made this horrifying speech, as you can imagine, the phones started ringing. Immediately, the Kennedy administration was besieged by people wanting more information on fallout shelters. I'm Kenneth D. Rose. I wrote One Nation Underground, the fallout shelter in American culture. You know, businesses that had previously been making swimming pools now declared themselves to be experts at building shelters.
那是制作人凯蒂·明格尔。正如你所想象的那样，在肯尼迪发表这番可怕的演讲后，电话铃声开始响起。肯尼迪政府立刻被要求提供有关防空洞更多信息的人们包围了。我是肯尼迪·D·罗斯。我写过《地下一个国家：美国文化中的防空洞》。你知道，以前制造游泳池的企业现在宣称自己是建造防空洞的专家。
They were door to door bomb shelter salesmen. Shelter displays at malls and county fairs. But by the time Kennedy made that 1961 speech, there was one place that had already broken ground on a unique shelter. Artesian New Mexico population 11,000 is about 40 miles south of Roswell in the southern part of the state near Texas.
他们是挨家挨户推销防空洞的推销员。购物中心和县集市上也有防空洞展览。但就在肯尼迪发表 1961 年那次演讲时，已经有一个地方开始为一个独特的防空洞动工了。新墨西哥州阿尔蒂西亚，人口 11,000 人，位于该州南部罗斯威尔以南约 40 英里处，靠近得克萨斯州。
And in 1962, they opened a brand new elementary school, completely underground, equipped with a morgue, decontamination showers, and a stockpile of food and medicine. Because this school, it was built to double as the town's nuclear fallout shelter. This was a pilot program with the idea of protecting school children and also members of the local community in case there was a nuclear attack. During an attack the school was supposedly with shelter its own students and those from other schools or the first 2100 people to show up
1962 年，他们启用了一所全新的小学，完全位于地下，配备了太平间、洗消淋浴间以及食品和药品库存。因为这所学校的建造目的之一就是兼作镇上的核防空洞。这是一个试点项目，其理念是在发生核袭击时保护学童以及当地社区成员。袭击发生期间，该学校理应为本校学生以及来自其他学校的学生或前 2,100 名到达者提供庇护。
and those who arrived late at the school would find their entry blocked by 1800 pounds steel doors And it is 821 and joining us in the studio this morning is Katie Mangle. She's up from Oakland, California and good morning How are you good? Thanks. Thanks for having me. Well, okay, first up, I guess you're good. Wait, what is going on? Alright, let me explain. I went to Artija, and because small towns are amazing, they invited me to come on their local radio station,
而那些迟到学校的人会发现他们的入口被 1,800 磅重的钢门挡住了。现在是 8 点 21 分，今天早上加入我们演播室的是凯蒂·曼格尔。她来自加利福尼亚州奥克兰，早上好，你好吗？很好，谢谢。谢谢邀请我。好吧，首先，我想你挺好的。等等，这到底是怎么回事？好吧，让我解释一下。我去了阿尔蒂西亚，因为小镇非常棒，他们邀请我上当地的广播电台，
KSVP, and put a call out for people who had gone to Abbo Elementary School as kids. Exactly, it was cool. Yeah. Good deal. So if anybody has information or stories you want to share about Abola, a mentor, be it a student there or administrator or maybe you worked on or whatever, give Katie a call once again her phone number is there. So did
KSVP，并呼吁小时候去过阿博小学的人们打电话来。没错，这很酷。是的。太好了。因此，如果任何人有关于阿博、导师的信息或故事想要分享，无论你是那里的学生还是管理员，或者也许你在那里工作过等等，请给凯蒂打电话，再次强调她的电话号码就在那里。那么，
people actually call you? Yeah, they did and we'll meet one of them later. But first let's go look at the school. Abola was tucked away in a quiet little neighborhood, not too far away from the center of town. You could easily miss it driving by since it's mostly underground, but there is a sign out front and you have to squint to make it out, but it says. Abo Elementary School and Fallout Shelter, and that's of course the original on there. That's Scott Simmer. My name is Scott Simmer and I'm currently the director of maintenance
真的有人给你打电话吗？是的，他们打了，我们稍后会见到其中一位。但首先我们去看看这所学校。阿博坐落在一个安静的小社区里，离镇中心不太远。开车经过时很容易错过它，因为它大部分在地下，但在正面有一个标志，你必须眯起眼睛才能看清楚，上面写着。阿博小学和防空洞，当然那是原版的标志。那是斯科特·西默。我叫斯科特·西默，目前担任公立学校的维护主管，
for the public schools, for Artigia Public Schools. I met Scott and Thad Fips, the current assistant superintendent of Artigia schools on the roof of ABO. The school is closed now, but kids still went to school there until 1995. The roof of ABO school is a concrete blacktop at ground level with basketball hoops and
为阿尔蒂西亚公立学校工作。我在阿博的屋顶上遇到了斯科特和阿尔蒂西亚学校现任副总学监萨德·菲普斯。这所学校现在已经关闭了，但孩子们一直在那里上学直到 1995 年。阿博学校的屋顶是地面水平的混凝土沥青路面，配有篮球架和
three covered stairways that go down underground and into the school. Like if you're in first grade you went down this set of doors. If you're in second and third you will come over here and then fourth and fifth graders would line up at this one. One mother described the scene of kids entering the building as looking like ants lining up to go into their ant hill. Scott and Dad actually both went to school at Abo in the late 70s, early 80s, and they said that even though the signout front says follow-out shelter, and even though their
三个有盖的楼梯，通往地下并进入学校。就像如果你读一年级，你就会走这组门。如果你读二三年级，你会过来，然后四五年级学生会在这个排队。一位母亲将孩子们进入大楼的场景形容为像蚂蚁排队进入蚁丘。斯科特和萨德其实都在 70 年代末、80 年代初上过阿博小学，他们说，尽管正面的标志写着防空洞，而且他们的
school was entirely underground, they never really knew what that meant. I never knew growing up that it was a built as a bombshell there. It was just a school to me as a kid, you know. And then once you get older and you, you know, you hear stories and all that used to have a morgue down here. And you know, Habbo Elementary was designed by an architect and civil defense enthusiast named Frank Stanthart. After he built Abbo School, he went on to design an underground shopping mall slash bomb shelter that was never actually built. Over here, this is our shower room. It gets the contaminants off of you before you come into the
学校完全在地下，但他们从未真正明白这意味着什么。我从小到大都不知道它是作为炸弹避难所建造的。对小时候的我来说它只是一所学校，你知道的。然后当你长大后，你知道，你听到一些传说，噢，这下面曾经有个太平间。你知道的，阿博小学是由一位名叫弗兰克·斯坦哈特的建筑师和民防爱好者设计的。在他建造了阿博学校之后，他又去设计了一个地下购物中心兼防空洞，但实际上从未建成。这里，这是我们的淋浴房。它能在你进入
rest of the people underground. The decontamination showers at each entrance were easy to miss, as were the blast doors which were swung up against a wall and not used during normal school days. You know, solid steel door. You can close it and it has three or four different latches to latch it so nobody can get in or out and never knew that this door existed till I started working here. and never knew that this door existed till I started working here. And so... We go down a couple flights of stairs into the main hallway of the school. And basically, it just looks like a school.
地下其余人群之前清除你身上的污染物。每个入口处的洗消淋浴很容易被忽视，防爆门也是如此，它们在平时上学日被推靠在墙上，不会被使用。你知道的，坚固的钢门。你可以把它关上，它有三四个不同的插销可以锁上，这样就没人能进出了，直到我在这里工作之前我从不知道这扇门的存在。直到我在这里工作之前我从不知道这扇门的存在。所以……我们走过几段楼梯，来到学校的主走廊。基本上，它看起来就像一所学校。
I mean, it's windowless and kind of drab since it hasn't been used in almost 20 years. But otherwise, it looks a bit like other schools I've been in. This is the kitchen area. Whenever you came to lunch from the classes, you always came through this door. You see back there, they had a big stage back there where we put on our productions for,
我的意思是，它没有窗户，而且有点单调，因为已经将近 20 年没有使用了。但除此之外，它看起来有点像我去过的其他学校。这是厨房区域。每当你们从教室来吃午餐时，总是通过这门进来。你们看后面，那里有一个大舞台，我们在那里进行演出，
I was in a few plays during grade school, so that's where it all happened. The kids at Abo actually got to vote on what the school mascot would be. And appropriately and adorably they chose to be the Abo Gofers. We're underground just like the Gofers are and so right through here is our generator room to keep it up and running for the people that are coming in inhabitants or whatever counts people that are coming here for the fallout.
我在小学时演过几部戏剧，所以一切都在那里发生。阿博的学生实际上投票决定了学校的吉祥物是什么。恰如其分又非常可爱的是，他们选择成为阿博地鼠。我们像地鼠一样在地下，所以穿过这里就是我们的发电机房，为到来的人们、居民或无论怎么计算来这里避难的人保持运转。
It also has right over here in the corner its own water well underground. And as you can tell right here, you've got doors, you've got to close that for survival, open this and for survival, and you're shutting ventilation shafts and open ventilation shafts and trying to keep the bad air out of here. Scott and Thad weren't sure which room doubled as the morgue. And I think it's back by the elevator. That's what I learned. There's a little room, but I didn't ever see where it could fit, you know, a tremendous
这里在角落里还拥有它自己的地下水井。正如你在这里所看到的，你有门，为了生存你必须关上它，打开这个为了生存，你要关闭通风井并打开通风井，试图把不好的空气挡在外面。斯科特和萨德不确定哪个房间兼作太平间。我想它在电梯后面。这就是我了解到的。有一个小房间，但我从没见过它能容纳，你知道的，大量
number of bodies. But this is a typical classroom. Certainly there's not any windows, there's not any sunlight, but we went upstairs two, three times a day for recreation. The teachers reported that they generally liked our school because the students weren't distracted by staring out the windows, and I think the students themselves were generally proud of other school. But once again, this creates a huge debate with many people saying that the needs of schools and the need to shelter people during a nuclear attack were not compatible.
的尸体。但这间是典型的教室。当然，没有任何窗户，没有任何阳光，但我们一天上楼两三次进行娱乐活动。老师们报告说，他们通常很喜欢我们的学校，因为学生们不会因为盯着窗户看而分心，而且我认为学生们自己通常为学校感到自豪。但话又说回来，这引发了巨大的争论，许多人表示，学校的需求与在核袭击期间庇护人们的需求并不兼容。
That's Kenneth Rose again, author of One Nation Underground, and he says in fact there was a lot of debate going on at the time about fallout shelters. The subject was virtually inescapable in the early 1960s. Every newspaper was running articles on shelters and the potential for survival. Time magazine published an article called Guns Eye Neighbor in which they interviewed a guy who said, that if any of his neighbors tried to get into his fallout shelter during a nuclear attack, he would kill them. It is fierce. Today you can watch shows like Doomsday Preppers on Cable TV and think about what it would be like to prepare for the apocalypse. But in the 1950s and 60s, it was a brand new idea. Also back then, it wasn't a fringe idea.
那是肯尼迪·罗斯，他是《地下一个国家》的作者，他说事实上当时关于防空洞有很多争论。在 20 世纪 60 年代初，这个话题几乎是无法回避的。每家报纸都在刊登关于防空洞和生存潜力的文章。《时代》杂志发表了一篇名为《持枪邻居》的文章，他们在文章中采访了一个人，他说如果他的任何邻居在核袭击期间试图进入他的防空洞，他就会杀死他们。这非常激烈。今天你可以在有线电视上观看像《末日准备者》这样的节目，并思考为世界末日做准备会是什么样子。但在 20 世纪 50 和 60 年代，这是一个全新的概念。而且在当时，这并不是一个边缘概念。
I mean, the president of the United States was telling people to build these things, and the whole country was involved in the debate. On one side of the debate, you had people against shelters. Those against shelter said that your people who burled into the ground to say their own skins were no better than moles or gofers. Shelters would militarize America and turn the United States into a garrison state. And after the nuclear war had ended, shelters would sort of be America's pyramids. All that remained of a wasted defunct civilization. And on the other side, people for shelters said,
我的意思是，美国总统告诉人们建造这些东西，整个国家都卷入了这场辩论。在辩论的一方，你有人反对防空洞。反对防空洞的人说，你们这些钻入地下以保全自己皮囊的人并不比鼢鼠或地鼠好多少。防空洞将使美国军事化，把美国变成一个兵营国家。核战争结束后，防空洞将某种程度上成为美国的金字塔。一个被废弃、消亡的文明仅存的遗迹。而在另一方，支持防空洞的人说，
wait a minute, this is just a precaution, like any other. They compared follow shelters to lifeboats. Here's a sarcastic letter that a proponent of shelters wrote to the Harvard Crimson in 1961. It's been brought to our attention that certain elements among the passengers and crew favor the installation of lifeboats on this ship. Although we share their concern,
等一下，这只是一种预防措施，和其他措施一样。他们把防空洞比作救生艇。这是 1961 年防空洞支持者写给《哈佛深红报》的一封讽刺信。有人提议我们注意，乘客和船员中的某些元素赞成在这艘船上安装救生艇。尽管我们分享他们的担忧，
we remain unalterably opposed to any consideration other course of action for the following reasons. The letter gets increasingly sarcastic. It demonstrates a lack of faith in our captain. The apparent security which lifeboats offer will make our navigators reckless. These proposals will distract our attention from more important things, i.e. building unseniable ships. You will only be saved for a
但由于以下原因，我们仍然坚决反对任何考虑其他行动方案的做法。信件变得越来越讽刺。它表现出对我们船长缺乏信心。救生艇提供的表面安全将使我们的领航员变得鲁莽。这些提案将分散我们对更重要事情的注意力，即建造不可沉没的船只。你只会被拯救以迎接
worst fate, inevitable death on the open seas, so far from so on. I think in this little letter, you can see some of the issues that are being debated. Like what kind of world will you emerge to if you survive a nuclear war? And whether the shelter system could somehow make our leaders more likely to engage in war. It's a very complicated calculus on this, this whole issue of whether to build a shelter or not to build a shelter. For the town of Artigia, in the early 1960s, the calculations seemed easy enough. They needed a new school anyway, and the Office of Civil Defense agreed to pay the difference between building a regular school and a fallout shelter school.
更糟糕的命运，在公海上不可避免的死亡，等等。我认为在这封小信中，你可以看到正在辩论的一些问题。比如如果你在核战争中幸存下来，你会进入一个什么样的世界？以及防空洞系统是否会以某种方式使我们的领导人更有可能参与战争。这是一个非常复杂的计算，关于是否建造防空洞或不建造防空洞的整个问题。对于阿尔蒂西亚镇来说，在 20 世纪 60 年代初，这些计算似乎相当简单。无论如何他们都需要一所新学校，而民防办公室同意支付建造普通学校与建造防空洞学校之间的差价。
Artisia was near Walker Air Force Base. It's closed now, but at the time it was the largest strategic air command base of the US Air Force. It was also close to the White Sands missile range. These and other factors made Artisia feel particularly vulnerable to attack. These and other factors made Artisia feel particularly vulnerable to attack. New Mexico has always had nuclear programs going on. That's John O'Williams. Her friend's mom is one of the people that heard me on the radio and got in touch. John went to Abu Elementary in the 1960s when Cold War tensions were still really high. I do remember going through white sand's missile range every once in a while
阿尔蒂西亚靠近沃克空军基地。它现在已经关闭了，但在当时它是美国空军最大的战略空军司令部基地。它也靠近白沙导弹靶场。这些和其他因素使阿尔蒂西亚感到特别容易受到攻击。这些和其他因素使阿尔蒂西亚感到特别容易受到攻击。新墨西哥州一直有核计划在进行。那是约翰娜·奥·威廉姆斯。她朋友的妈妈是在广播里听到我并取得联系的人之一。约翰娜在 20 世纪 60 年代冷战紧张局势仍然非常高涨时上了阿博小学。我确实记得偶尔穿过白沙导弹靶场，
you see a missile going up and you're thinking wow how do we have 30 minutes to live or what you know it's kind of a creepy feeling. Like that in Scott that gave me the tour of Abo, John I didn't know it first why her school was underground. The teachers never mentioned it and her parents didn't tell her either. They didn't tell us anything and don't ask real questions. We'll lie to you. But you know how most kids have that one friend in elementary school that knows about sex? Well, Johnna had Fidelia Brennan and she knew about nuclear war. Fidelia Brandon, I'll never forget. She's the one who opened my eyes to that kind of, I guess, reality or unreality. She was very intelligent. Of course, they had a fallout shelter in their backyard, so I'm sure they had already gone through the whole survivalist thing
你看到一枚导弹升空，然后你想，哇，我们怎么有 30 分钟的生命或者什么的，你知道，这是一种毛骨悚然的感觉。像带我参观阿博的斯科特和萨德一样，约翰娜起初也不知道为什么她的学校在地下。老师从没提过，她父母也没告诉过她。他们什么都没告诉我们，也别问真正的问题。我们会对你撒谎的。但你知道大多数孩子在小学里都有一个懂性知识的朋友吗？好吧，约翰娜有菲德莉亚·布伦南，她懂核战争。菲德莉亚·布伦南，我永远不会忘记。她是那个让我看到那种，我想，现实或非现实的人。她非常聪明。当然，他们的后院有一个防空洞，所以我确信他们在成长过程中已经经历了整个生存主义的事情，你知道的，了解孩子们和她的家庭，看起来他们被教导了诸如如何在核大屠杀中生存之类的事情。我知道在那之后我对那件事有一种怪异的感觉。就像，哦，天哪，我们都要死了！哦，给你！正当我和约翰娜在交谈时，警报器开始响了。这是炼油厂每周一晚上 6:30 播放的紧急测试警报。阿尔蒂西亚大型炼油厂是使他们在 60 年代感到容易受到攻击的另一件事。炼油厂在战争期间通常是目标，尤其是那些制造致命燃料的炼油厂，就像阿尔蒂西亚的那座一样。这听起来几乎就像核雨的声音，不是吗？作为孩子，这就是你如何知道“活泼的露西”要播出了。
growing up and, you know, knowing the kids and her family, it seems like they were taught things like how you could survive nuclear holocaust. I know I had kind of a freaky feeling about that after that. Like, oh my gosh, we're all gonna die! Oh, there you go! As Janna and I are talking, an alarm starts going off. It's an emergency test alarm that the oil refinery plays every Monday at 6.30pm. Artisia's large oil refinery was another thing that made them feel vulnerable to attack in the 60s. Refineries are often targets during wars, especially the ones that make death fuel like the one in Artisia did. It's almost like a nuclear rain sound, isn't it? That's how you knew that High-Live Lucy was coming on with as a kid.
从小到大，你知道的，认识那些孩子和她的家人，感觉他们被教导了一些事情，比如如何在核浩劫中生存。我知道在那之后我对此有一种诡异的感觉。就像，哦天哪，我们都要死了！哦，给你！正当我和贾娜在交谈时，警报器响了起来。这是炼油厂每周一晚上6点30分播放的紧急测试警报。阿蒂西亚的大型炼油厂是另一件让他们在60年代感到容易受到攻击的事情。炼油厂往往是战争期间的目标，尤其是那些生产死亡燃料的炼油厂，就像阿蒂西亚的那座一样。这听起来有点像核雨的声音，不是吗？作为一个孩子，这就是你如何知道“高空露西”要播出了。
When Abbo was built, it got a fair amount of media attention. Dan Rather did a story on the CBS evening news in 1962 and more than 60,000 people toward the school in its first few years. The Soviets found out about it and were critical. One Moscow newspaper criticized artisans for indoctrinating pupils to the inevitability of war. But actually, while the rest of the country's students
阿博建造时，获得了相当多的媒体关注。丹·拉瑟在 1962 年的哥伦比亚广播公司晚间新闻中报道了这个故事，在头几年有超过 60,000 人参观了这所学校。苏联人发现了这一点并进行了批评。一家莫斯科报纸批评阿尔蒂西亚向小学生灌输战争不可避免的思想。但事实上，当全国其他地区的学生
were doing duck and cover drills, which was probably strange and scary for some kids, Johnna doesn't ever remember having to do one at ABO. He got me and got me. But we never did any nuclear raid tests having to do one at a bow. But we never did any, you know, like nuclear raid tests where we had to drop tech and roll and all that kind of stuff. We were already down there, we were safe. So. Be sure and remember what Bert the Turtle just did, friends,
都在做俯卧掩护演习时，这对某些孩子来说可能既奇怪又可怕，约翰娜却不记得在阿博做过。她抓住了我，抓住了我。但我们从未做过任何核袭击测试，比如必须在阿博做。但我们从未做过任何，你知道的，类似核袭击测试的事情，我们必须扑倒并翻滚以及所有那些乱七八糟的事情。我们已经在地下了，我们很安全。所以。一定要记住伯特海龟刚刚做了什么，朋友们，
because every one of us must remember to do the same thing. That's what this film is all about. Duck and cover. This is an official civil defense film produced in the Soviet Union. We're putting down the US for their preoccupation with this whole shelter issue. But in fact, the Soviets built a very elaborate secret shelter underneath Moscow. And of course, our fearless leaders had their own hiding places. The most elaborate one being the bunker hidden below the Green Briar Resort in West Virginia, built the house all 535 members of Congress and their staff, but not their families.
因为我们每个人都必须记住做同样的事情。这就是这部电影的全部意义。俯卧掩护。这是苏联制作的官方民防影片。我们在指责美国全神贯注于整个防空洞问题。但事实上，苏联人在莫斯科地下建造了一个非常精致的秘密防空洞。当然，我们无畏的领导者也有他们自己的藏身之处。最精致的一个是隐藏在西弗吉尼亚州绿蔷薇度假村地下的地堡，旨在容纳所有 535 名国会议员及其员工，但不包括他们的家属。
It was decommissioned in 1995 and is now open for tours. Remember the speech that we heard at the beginning of this story, in which Kennedy vowed to allocate millions of dollars to find places where Americans could take shelter from nuclear bombs? Well, it took place in July of 1961. To identify and march face the existing structure of the Canfrey. It could be used to fall out shelters in case of attack. In the fall of 1962, during the Cuban Missile Crisis, Kennedy asked for a status report and found that his shelter program was far behind schedule.
它于 1995 年退役，现在对参观者开放。还记得我们在故事开头听到的演讲吗？肯尼迪在演讲中发誓要拨出数百万美元来寻找美国人可以躲避核炸弹的地方。嗯，它发生在 1961 年 7 月。确定并标记现有建筑。它可以用来在发生袭击时作为防空洞。在 1962 年秋天的古巴导弹危机期间，肯尼迪要求提供一份状态报告，发现他的防空洞计划远远落后于进度。
The government hadn't been able to find all that many places where people could take shelter, and the ones they had found weren't fully stocked with supplies. By 1962, the private shelter business was also failing. But it wasn't in decline because Americans stopped being afraid of nuclear war. The Cuban Missile Crisis was arguably the most frightening moment of the Cold War. Kenneth Rose thinks Americans rejected shelters for a lot of reasons. For one, they couldn't afford them. The cost of a decent shelter was about $2,500. And that was about half of the median family income in the 1960s.
政府没能找到那么多人们可以避难的地方，而他们找到的那些也没有完全储备物资。到 1962 年，私人防空洞业务也陷入困境。但它衰退并不是因为美国人不再害怕核战争。古巴导弹危机可以说是冷战中最令人恐吓的时刻。肯尼迪·罗斯认为美国人拒绝防空洞有很多原因。首先，他们买不起。一个像样的防空洞的成本约为 2,500 美元。这大约是 1960 年代美国家庭收入中位数的一半。
And Dr. Rose also believes. Americans simply did not like the image of themselves cowering underground. I think it dug at American pride. We think roughly something like 200,000 shelters were built from the beginning of the Cold War to about 1965. And you could say that, well, 200,000, that's a lot of shelters. It's about one for every 900 people. But in an era when a majority of Americans actually believe that there was going to be nuclear war between the US and the Soviet Union, I would say that 200,000 is actually a small number. Cause somebody tells me that death's coming round
罗斯博士还认为。美国人根本不喜欢自己蜷缩在地下的形象。我认为这损害了美国的自尊心。我们认为从冷战开始到大约 1965 年，大约建造了 200,000 个防空洞。你可以说，嗯，20,000 个，那有很多防空洞。大约每 900 人有一个。但在大多数美国人实际上认为美国和苏联之间将爆发核战争的时代，我会说 20 万其实是一个很小的数字。因为有人告诉我死神正在临近
And I will not carry myself down to die When I go to my grave and my head will be high Let me die in my footsteps Before I go down under the ground. As been rumors of war and war. As far as aboellum entry, it thankfully never had to serve as a fallout shelter, and they got rid of their supplies back in 1989. They had rid of all the bedding and the food, the medicine, even a few body bags.
而我不会把自己带去死去当我走向我的坟墓时我的头会抬得高高的让我死在我的足迹里在我深入地下之前。至于阿博小学，谢天谢地，它从未作为防空洞使用过，他们在 1989 年就处理掉了他们的物资。他们处理掉了所有的寝具、食物、药品，甚至还有几个尸袋。
But the school stayed open until 1995. When they stopped using it as a school, it wasn't because they were tired of being underground. Here's assistant superintendent, Thadfibs. It is a little sad after growing up in this school to see it not being used or to see it in this type of shape, but we understand as a district the cost to renovate this type of building was more than what the community was willing to put into it. So we built a brand new school right on almost on top of it, just slightly to the west. The new school is called Yeso Elementary. Yeso and ABO are both named after geological layers of Earth. YASO being in the layer just above ABO. It's clever.
但学校一直开到 1995 年。当他们停止将其作为学校使用时，并不是因为他们厌倦了呆在地下。这里是副总学监萨德·菲普斯。在这所学校长大后，看到它不再使用或看到它变成这种形状有点难过，但作为学区，我们理解翻修这种建筑的成本超过了社区愿意投入的资金。所以我们在它正上方几乎完全相同的位置建造了一所全新的学校，只是稍微偏西一点。新学校被称为耶索小学。耶索和阿博都是以地球的地质层命名的。耶索位于阿博之上的地层。这很聪明。
YASO is above ground, but in the spirit of ABO Elementary has very few windows. Now ABO Elementary is used for district storage, and one other thing. It's being used as an active shooter training facility for the Federal Law Enforcement Training Center. They go through all of their scenarios and use it to practice for situations that none of us want to think what happened. But school shootings that you know have been around the nation. This has been a really good facility to use because it's all downstairs there's no windows
耶索在地面以上，但秉承阿博小学的精神，它几乎没有窗户。现在阿博小学被用作学区仓库，还有另一项用途。它被联邦执法培训中心用作现役枪手训练设施。他们经历所有的情景，并用它来练习我们谁都不想去想会发生的情况。但你知道全国各地都发生过校园枪击事件。这真的是一个很好的设施，因为全都在楼下，没有窗户，
and they can do everything that they need to do and nobody, nobody sees. So twice a month, the Federal Law Enforcement Training Center goes into ABO and practices for school shootings, running drills, firing at fake targets. If something ever happens, you want to be prepared. I don't think you can ever be prepared enough, but in case something does happen. Because if there's one thing Artija has always been good at, it's being prepared and protecting its kids from whatever dangers they might confront. 99% invisible was produced this week by Katie Mingle with Sam Greenspan, Avery Trouffleman, and me Roman Mars.
他们可以做他们需要做的一切，而且没有人，没有人看到。因此，联邦执法培训中心每月两次进入阿博，练习校园枪击事件应对，进行演习，向假目标射击。如果真的发生了什么事，你希望做好准备。我认为你永远无法做好足够的准备，但以防万一真的发生了什么。因为如果说阿尔蒂西亚一直擅长一件事，那就是做好准备并保护其孩子免受他们可能面临的任何危险。99% Invisible 本周由凯蒂·明格尔与萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼和我罗曼·马斯共同制作。
We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and produced out of the offices of ArcSign Architecture and Beautiful Downtown Oakland, California. If you like the stories on this program, you can get more and more and more of it at Facebook, Twitter and Tumblr, but photos of ABO await at 99pi.org. Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是旧金山 91.7 本地公共广播电台 KALW 的一个项目，在 ArcSign 建筑事务所和美丽的奥克兰市中心办公室制作。如果你喜欢这个节目中的故事，你可以在 Facebook、Twitter 和 Tumblr 上获取更多、更多、更多的内容，但阿博的照片在 99pi.org 等着你。Radio Tapio。来自 PRX。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。